A droid-filled city features prominently
in the new episode of "The Mandalorian,"
and one of those background bots
even had a bit part in "The Empire
Strikes Back." Here's the throwback
robot cameo you may have missed.
Season 3 of "The Mandalorian" picks
up where we last left off — that is,
provided you've watched the Din Djarin bits
of "The Book of Boba Fett" and know what he
and Grogu have been up to. As is the series'
custom, it also features numerous nods at
the many canon and non-canon stories from
the history of the Galaxy Far, Far Away.
In other words, the Season 3 premiere
features lots of cool droids. The most
prominent of them is, of course, IG-11, whose
self-destruction sequence in Season 1 apparently
wasn't enough to entirely demolish his body,
and whom Mando is now trying to get revived
for the sake of having some reliable-ish
backup on his upcoming Mandalore jaunt.
"I need him back."
"IG-11 was destroyed on the lava
river. This is just a statue."
However, the episode's backdrop of
the surprisingly spruced-up Nevarro
City hides plenty of other mechanical marvels
to behold, from the tiny droids hauling Greef
Karga's cape to various protocol droids. In
fact, one of these cameos just so happens
to mark the unexpected return of a long-lost
deep cut character from the "Star Wars" lore.
Early on in the episode, Din and Grogu
are walking the streets of the city,
taking in the sights and
marveling at the overhaul.
"A lot has changed around here."
On their way, they briefly pass
a bright white protocol droid
that a few hardcore fans will
no doubt recognize as K-3PO.
This white-colored droid resembling
C-3PO first appeared in "Star Wars:
Episode 5 — The Empire Strikes Back" as a member
of the Rebels, but he's mainly been a niche
fixture of the "Star Wars" canon since then. Based
on this brief glimpse, it's rather likely that the
monochrome droid is not actually the exact same
character fans first witnessed fighting the good
fight in "The Empire Strikes Back," but the visual
design of the model is still quite unmistakable.
Apart from his original movie debut, K-3PO
has popped up in a few other entries in
the franchise. He's gotten some cameos
in the "Star Wars Battlefront" games,
featured in a small role for several of the
"LEGO Star Wars" games, and has appeared
in a couple other pieces of secondary and
non-canon franchise material. Nonetheless,
"The Mandalorian" marks the oft-forgotten
droid's highest-profile appearance in years.
While the K-3PO droid unit that appears in
the Season 3 premiere of "The Mandalorian"
may not be the same one that originally
appeared in "The Empire Strikes Back,"
some fans may nonetheless be
curious about the role that the
character originally played in the movie.
Suffice to say, it's not a very big one.
Like his counterpart on "The Mandalorian," K-3PO
is mostly resigned to being a background character
in several scenes. He's seen working with the
Rebels' equipment at their secret base on the
icy planet Hoth, and he's present when the
iconic Battle of Hoth breaks out. Of course,
this epic "Star Wars" battle doesn't
really go all that well for the Rebels,
and K-3PO is summarily destroyed in the
chaos during the planet's evacuation.
Considering that the K-3PO on "The Mandalorian"
is in perfect condition, and the show takes place
years after "The Empire Strikes Back," it's
probably not the same one from the original
movie. However, destroyed droids like IG-11 have
been brought back to life before, so there's still
a possibility these two units are one and the
same. If "The Mandalorian" ever elects to give
this smaller "Star Wars" character a bigger role,
perhaps fans will finally get a definitive answer.